you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on leech s
org
and
paired up playing a 15-10 game against
BB zan
try let's try carica first time playing
this opponent
let's put a pond in the center alrighty
so now advanced variation
a chop
okay now from here I have a decision
I'm most comfortable with Knight to f6
I could give that a shot
go down and down a mainline I have
another option hmm yeah I think I might
want to experiment yeah I think I'm an
experiment
good it is
it's an early early decision to make a
pond move like this but
I saw I saw Lila play this in one of the
games I'm not sure how long ago this was
needless chess is zero for those of you
who may not be familiar the neural net
anyhow I think one of the ideas is to
not only well two ideas keep the night
out but I don't think that's the primary
reason it's maybe to enter a mainline
where you don't you're you can kinda
just back up in one move like if I go
Bishop here there's Knight back
for this there's h4 here here the bishop
takes three moves
to get to h7 so I guess in a way I'll be
able to get to h7 in just two moves
am I missing any details I don't think
so so let's see what white does like g3
No okay so just push up there I mean
this isn't some waste more long-term I'm
happy about having a flight square for
my King I have to slow down a little bit
I
I play bullet and blitz so much it's
tough to adjust to a slower game
Bishop's unprotected this is useful
let's secure the bishop
it's actually not necessary to protect
the bishop directly I do have a a check
and then
and recapture an f5 though sometimes my
experience with this type of recapture
an f5 could run into some trouble as
Queen a5 c3 and after recapture Queen b3
is hard to meet with the Queen kind of
offside and committed on the Kings side
not around to defend this point
this isn't a direction we go in
white is coordinating on d6 I'm thinking
about Knight f6 and not really too much
else here the knight drops in
so I think I want to challenge the
knight takes takes
bishop here
that can be
a little bit irritating actually huh I'm
have to be a little bit careful
have six Knight takes Knight I
definitely want to be able to recapture
here as there's pressure on my bishop
so here takes takes Bishop e5 and if I
move my Queen and defend my Bishop
there's Knight h4 yuck okay I don't
think I could play Knight up six I may
have to just be satisfied with giving up
my bishop for the night I do have a nice
structure with my remaining bishop
I'm gonna do that and well hi gain a
valuable tempo now with Knight f6 I must
say it was very tempting to just play
Knight f6 without
inserting this capture first but think
it's important so there are some
additional Tempe I could gain against a
bishop with a knight moving forward I
don't think it's a wise choice here
Bishop d6 seems sensible like working
with the bishop pair offer a bishop
exchange yeah let's go for it
here I cannot challenge the night with
97 okay just I guess we're gonna go into
it's gonna it's going to continue Tony
slow path
I don't know if I want to invite the
Queen forward I'm actually thinking
about Queen c7 I want to fight some for
the dark squares yeah I think I may just
want to play Queen c7 and 97 takes takes
I don't like that the Queen is kind of
stopping my Queen from
playing to a useful a very nice square
and c7 I'll just go a queen c7
first time
this opponent
I like playing the rapid okay so here we
are the main imbalance here is related
to night versus bishop solid structure
for me solid structure for white white
has a tiny bit of space
it's a d4 versus e six structure call it
okay
already all
there's one move I have to be on the
lookout for it's 95 that can certainly
be a very disruptive piece
to challenge this pawn in the center
with c5 certainly not e5
where else is this guy gonna go let's
get them in in the game I'm expecting a
centralization supporting 95 where do I
want to go with my king I think Queen
side especially now that I have this
pawn up one step
could very easily see a g4 g5 even even
giving up upon and I take G for Rick G
one and then a white is quick to rip the
heart out of my kingside structure
now if the night arrives on e5 I can't
take it queenside castle here I'd end up
in a fork how am i huh Mike dealing with
this 95 move
what I could do I have to be a little
bit careful on no and I'm now in a pin
so this guy is powerless I'm considering
backing up the Queen so that when the
night plays here I can take
and then and then I guess play Knight d7
and focus on this pawn a little bit
Castle queenside
I think I think this is eventually going
to change somewhat the structure I think
I can't tolerate a knight on e5 and so
I'll have to take a knight the pawn is
going to recapture I'll need to find a
new home for my knight on f6 and I think
the best square would be d7 exerting
pressure on the pawn going to d5 he's
sure to be kicked and I'll have to find
a new home from there d6 is going to be
a weak point very soon in my position
after especially after a capture with
the deep on white intersects there
anything else besides Queen c7 here I
would love to have the Queen's off but I
don't see how I managed that
all right
Queen c7 it is
all right this is a game of inches to be
sure no haymakers in this one
white remains better development wise
minor piecewise
pawn presents in the center wise so my
idea was to take the knight
have something else
let's do it
pressure on the pond and one day maybe
get rid of the bishop
all right now might be a moment to make
this move hmm I can't go without King
queenside castle so I think I have to
get that move in now
yeah makes sense
so white still has the advantage a bit
more now structurally
and it ties in very well
pawns fixed on dark these guys are
potential targets okay
sky's under fire mmm I guess I guess
we're gonna look at Queen b6 I don't see
something else this is my first thought
think it's a good one not really too
concerned about Queen here just play
that Queen b6 Queen exchange I think
I'll take with the pond
yeah let's do it how much more are we
gonna simplify are we gonna go there are
we are we going yeah maybe we're going
right down to like King and King King
versus King game
some hands shake our hands all right so
my I think my night is just misplaced
taking here I want to keep this option
open yeah I'll take with the pun I like
the idea of being able to expand here
huh well actually a little bit happy now
that the queens are off this this space
that white has isn't so
hmmm how to describe it it's not really
sure how to explain myself here I think
it might be more valuable having this
Space Invader pond with the Queens on
the board somehow light working with the
d6 square
okay and you know I think this is just a
fantastic reply I know I'm putting a
upon on a light square but this is ultra
useful one pun restricting these two
so also
the other thing
have a square for my night
where is d5 now I need to be careful
about what exactly the thing that is on
my mind at this stage is what pieces do
I want to play with in this position I
do not want to play this position where
both rooks are exchanged
I think I'm simply worse
and
this bishop
as night
is a bit more of an issue also I I first
see that my rook will maybe have an
easier time targeting one of the white
pawns so I want to keep one rook on so
here
now I think I want to go here first
actually if I do this
there's rook takes rook rook takes rook
rook here and then
I mean I could I could hop in here it is
something to consider
it is something to consider let's see
Knight b6 or King c7 how can I reason
these two moves out
have any other moves on my radar so
which one is better
[Music]
you
well
I'm gonna step up
useful move King needs to be on c6 he's
happy being on a dark square I wish my
opponent with things some more already
so now I'm ready for Knight b6 I'm not
really afraid of upon recapturing here
and becoming past I think it's a it'd be
a goner
I'd be able to hunt that pond down hide
behind him and track him down
my nighttime b6 is going to be an
excellent piece as wonderful jumping
points a for the
of the three I'm not sure about night a
four but certainly c4 and d5 nice
forward moves and in this in the sweet
16
so finally white is at least thinking
all right so let's do this I I want one
rock on
so now after a chopper Oni and a
recapture I could play two AAA I think I
might be close to better here yeah I
could be close to better the night on c5
is a pretty annoying piece okay got to
start with this
this would be a good way to have the
game end King here Fork
okay well
here's enough I mean I
to have some interesting ideas one is to
go here force the King to be one that's
a demotion and then maybe I could
consider opening something up over here
though
I try to open stuff up over here this
will be a sensitive point accessible
potentially to a rook depending on you
know if white captures and I would
really like to have my King here so if
this recovery moves off of this file I
think I'd I kind of want to scoot on
over to e7
how about this direct stuff rook a a
king b1 rook here this is an only move
what about Ravi a king b1 rook here
Aven there's the offer of rook exchange
that's it this is a useful move for the
rook then it could start poking around
and my pawns hahaha
I'm just
sure yeah I could
oh okay
maybe this here this provokes seeds free
and then I feel more confident about
playing this because if take stakes
there isn't a rook c3 move and the rook
can't make use of the C file squares I
may want to provoke c3 and then drop my
knight in to d5 let me start with this
we're more time to really think this one
through I'd I'd love to be able to
really go deep into this endgame
subtle points inducing little moves and
yeah anyhow I think King bun oh no no
I'm sorry King p1 is not necessary c3
could be played right here for you
totally overlook that but I do have a
knight d5 move at some stage
here's another thing maybe I could
consider
f5
okay I think I might want to try f5 f5
if takes on Poisson I'll recapture and
then I don't don't worry about this I
can maybe start putting pressure over
here
I want to keep my night kind of flexible
and if this and the bishop moves then I
could jump in here or here attacking the
rook and stopping rook d6 I'd have to
worry about this base point once I play
a5
here Bishop back
I have the g5 mover I'm sorry here
Bishop back I have this and then g5 the
Rick is tied down for the moment
make sense to do this right now then the
rook is going to have to go to one of
these three night here right now maybe
I want to keep the Knights out options
open still
I want to try this
yeah let's
f-five
it really is a lot to consider with
these structural changes so there's
there's a couple different structural
changes to really assess with the move
f5 is white going to take and you know
well it's a completely different
structure or or not and it just remains
locked is this going to be a liability
or an asset or I'm sorry it's a target
is it accessible is something I'd be
questioning so
let's see decision time pawn takes pawn
and then those who are not educated
enough with the game proclaim what is
that about
his white cheating if this guy goes here
and this pond disappears white is not
cheating on Poisson all right let's see
what is he gonna come up with well my I
have an easy reply after a capture so
let's consider what I would do if the
bishop moves to let's say f3 I think I
know I think I want to just play here
straight away
Bishop leaves control of this square a
Knight d5 move is gonna be wonderful
yeah okay so I think now I want to play
g5
you
first stop night stop rook d6 I got to
go faster let's let's let's commit okay
rook you got three options you have a
responsibility
next up g5 I think
how much further
go here here maybe this and then I go up
like that get my pawn all the way down
to 8th h3 have this structure okay let's
do it
don't have any fancy tactic no I don't
see it ooh
have an opportunity to quickly transfer
the rook and I think this kind of stuff
is very slow so I think it's a rook type
of
game what do I mean by that I think it's
a who's going to have the better rook
I'm not sure who has the better minor
piece in this case my Knights standing
pretty nice
quite an invasive piece whoo now things
are definitely sharpening up did not
consider that move is that even good
though I mean I could take pawn takes
pawn pawn takes pawn isn't this starting
to become an issue
are they only seeing that I take here
and then they're on that but I could
take on that for what's wrong with that
I don't know I'm just gonna take the
phone and oh here's the other thing I
don't have to take here straight away I
could take on e5 hitting the bishop I
have a check in mind but here here here
here you know I wouldn't mind that after
this I feel like I could hang on to both
pawns
which one is it now that I'm at 3:22 I
got the 10 second increment name up upon
going to be up upon maybe more oh I have
night here as well
tell you what I'm gonna go here I like
taking the pawn and throwing a punch at
the bishop and being within striking
distance even if this move I'm okay so
I'm going to take and now my rook is
going to be the one who gets very active
let's start with this let's let's force
white to make it a decision with the
bishop okay no what about here
and then here I think I want to step up
let's let's get let's get going that's a
passer I think that's a blender I think
I think I'm going to win now
for the bishop can't move too far and if
there's no more pressure here I have
knight Knight g4 push knight h2 at
control the promotion square think I'm
just advancing
I think I'm just pushing through with
the past phone
f-for
then just up upon
yeah I don't know I'm not
or what exactly uh I'm not sure what
exactly happened there White's decision
with g4 I was a little bit I don't think
that was a mouse lip was g3 really
intended and in see any like take back
take back requests maybe it was a mouse
slip you know cuz this is what I was
expecting g3 but I would think they
would have thrown a take back at me in
for a rapid game I think I may have
allowed that take back because this just
seems way too I don't know
I can't make sense of it that's a sudden
end to this one a 32 mover hmm
with this one I don't know if I'll be
revisiting this it's it's interesting
you know Bishop f5 Bishop h7 here's the
well I'll just jump into the analysis
board right now if I go with the main
line this is usually this is the usual
path for the bishop boom boom
well let's get some moves on first
Bishop f5 bishop g6 Knight here this h4
boom boom boom how many moves of that 1
2 3 so it looks to save a move and you
know not not give this valuable tempo
alright and not give a valuable tempo to
white with these pawn advances
generating threats and gaining space I
don't know it's just looking for
something a little bit different to be
honest this is this is what I've played
more than anything else even over the
board games this Knight f6 move with the
recapture the Jeep on makes for an
interesting structure and I don't know I
just wanted to travel down a little bit
of a different path though it did turn
out to be quite normal in this game let
me go get the arrows off oh and let me
click on the computer analysis did this
once before
try it one more time yeah I think in a
little bit it might be crunching the
numbers right now even though this is
still there so I'll check back in a
minute
I got to express a lot I think I'll kind
of pay a bit more attention to the
endgame
it's nuts um I'm losing Hoover anything
h6 okay anyhow Bishop at five he six
just kind of skipping through here with
a an eye on these lines yeah okay I did
make a good decision here I think I'm
losing if I play Knight f6 seems very
natural but yeah I'm kind of just lost
I think plus one point four chop chop
Bishop b5 it's not fun giving your queen
a responsibility like this to defend the
bishop just I'd be dead
okay so I got to take the night I did
and only then Knight f6
d sex
chips what was my big concern with this
I wanted to be here some of this this
hmm uh
rook c8 again with this pawn here I do
not want to go into opposite sides
Castle position I'm really asking for
trouble even if it's reading a zero
no this is this is one of those
positions where you have to be you can't
trust the evaluation here I just don't
think it's a wise choice to to enter
that kind of ball game mm-hmm no way I I
wanted to gain some control over the
dark squares I wanted my Queen to have a
nice square
it's planning on queenside castle and
yeah why did why does the better side
hear how it wants to go at c5 oh that
looks so scary b5 when I'm still a
couple moves behind their castled I'm
not and I'm opening up this file for the
major pieces no way now there's just too
much to be considering there okay Knight
B to d7 in the end eventually comes
around to that route d8
now I had in my mind the queenside
castle so chop-chop
just a tiny plus for team White Queen F
to Queen b6 are they is it done with the
analysis what's going on with the
analysis are we going to be able to get
it Oh
are you gonna be able to see any pieces
mm-hmm Oh what's going on
let's try refresh
there we go everything is wonderful okay
let's take a quick peek inaccuracies
mistakes blunders for each side all
right well we're close to an end game
now and I guess ah yeah you see that b4
move right soon as B form the B form of
was in
yeah this isn't a good isn't a good idea
this pond loves playing to be five
on two holes
I start to be better now after b4 so a4
is a much better move to stop me from
expanding
okay yeah I mean this is instructed
moment regarding pawn play clampdown
this is what I want to do this is like
upon slinky the head the head has to
move forward before the tail can can
move and yeah I want to play b5 why can
stop it okay B for a five I'm a tiny bit
better here I was torn between these two
moves okay in the end King c7 I'm not
really sure if during the game I
expressed myself as well as I can with
this idea of what pieces I wanted to
keep on the board if it's a minor piece
a specific position I just think that
white stands better yeah I just think
white stands better I want to be able to
target something
I want to maybe try and undermine this
pawn but there's no undermining this
pawn with just the the minor pieces on I
don't see really how that's possible
another thing is if there is if I don't
if I don't have a rook if we're playing
with no rooks on the board this King
will find it much easier to take up a
nice central post maybe that's one of
the the things that is kind of in the
back of my mind but I'm only now
expressing it this space would enable
the white king to ultimately establish a
superior King position and I would like
to keep a rook around so that I can
maybe challenge the king should it try
and take up a central post
okay so anyhow from here night b61 rook
is off I would be very surprised if this
was the suggestion it's not I think I
would lose the advantage if I do this
yeah so
this is so much easier like for example
a king on d4 how do I win that I'm not
winning that so I need to keep a rook on
a h5
that I want to play h5 put another pawn
on a light square that's what keeps me
from that's what makes me cringe when I
see the suggestion h5
King B 1 C 3 is even better than move
played in the game
alpha is f5 a move here now it's
suggesting rook a3 h5 once more but f5
is not too far off it's not it's not
upset let's just say with the move f5 I
still I still hold on to something it
does turn out to be a growing advantage
so I guess I in the end game I I played
I played ok this was the other structure
I was being funny during the game about
on Poisson
I think I'm doing our right here with
this structure no worries anymore with
this and I think I'll be the one that
has a more active rook
you know a lot of this is really coming
back to the B for move I mean upon on b5
a night on b6 this configuration is
excellent and the night has great
jumping points the king has to feel
pretty uneasy my King is really tucked
in nice dark square no fear of a rook
check or a bishop check can't say the
same for the king
where's his cozy square not sure
so f5 Bishop f3
I guess I'm I might be winning now this
seems pretty significant 1.5 advantage
Kirksey to g6 and g6 g5 this was my idea
and even if g3 is played I'm uh I'm
doing all right I was
attention and maybe I do this and get
this pawn all the way down here and
maybe there's some timely sacrifices and
I could push through very fast here's
another thing I'm even seeing a position
where the bishop could be in the on the
corner square and have no good squares
along this diagonal this would kind of
be funny of course different moves could
be played but if the bishop goes here
now I could now think about exchange or
exchanging rooks because the bishop what
is it going to do
and you know some fantasy variation
what what is the suggestion though from
here King be six I don't think I would
have played King be six I think
something like this and then maybe a
timely capture and invasion is something
I would lean towards
rook a6 what is the point with rook a
six let's just make I don't know
sing move and now g4 h5
something related to this just kind of
inching up with these pawns little by
little and I could afford to do this
this is a slow position where there's no
constructive plan for white all pawns
are frozen and how do you work around
this guy and c4 he's he's an MVP
well it's interesting all right g4 is
just a game losing move I have my my
pick here I was trying to work out
something even considered that
which I guess is still winning but this
is good enough
I am up a pond and there's no stopping
them
brook f4 so this is where white resigned
if it continued oh I don't know I guess
Bishop here Knight g4 they take sage to
and I can return push and now I have
whoops two different squares I control
the queening square and I will push next
get a queen
okay anyhow a bit of a sudden end to
this 132 mover yeah this was the final
moment final move rook rook f4 as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you